hey what's up guys it's marquez from the  mkbhd channel happy friday and welcome  to forum friday where one friday of  every month we ask for a simple question  that requires a pretty simple answer for  this friday the question is this what is  your current phone is it a gigantic  mothership of a smartphone for you or is  it just a phone my answer right now is  the motorola droid hey don't judge i  have a good reason for it i'm waiting  for this guy  right there  the most popular answer below will be  revealed in next month's form friday  episode so thanks in advance for your  comment so without any further ado here  are the best answers from last month's  forum friday episode which asked  what is your favorite web browser  [Music]  you